well let's talk more about what's
happening in Hearthstone this defense
and security analyst Professor Michael
Clark joins us um
Michael what's the latest in the city
because obviously there's this
Jubilation uh that they've been
liberated people are coming in including
journalists and more aid but the big
question is what next what yeah I mean
they're having a great time zielinski's
had a great moment uh being there for
the flag raising ceremony but they'll
need more great moments like this before
this business is concluded because the
battle for Kirsten is only half over
they've got the city but the city's not
safe so they've got the other half of
the battle still to win in effect
and what about the Strategic importance
of taking her son for the war itself
exactly so the Russians are on the other
side of the river so they're on the
Eastern side of the NEPA river that
means that the within artillery range
occursome when they got thrown off out
of khaki earlier in the war they stood
out and they just lobbed artillery
shells into the City and and the
ukrainians had to launch big attacks to
push them out of artillery range and
that's what the ukrainians will have to
do here they've got to get the Russians
another 30 kilometers or so away from a
person in order to keep them out of
artillery range now they they seem to
have landed on the kinburn spit in the
last 36 hours at uh the Russians now
admit that the ukrainians have got to
hit a whisk now all that area is all
marshy bogland it's lots of tributaries
as you would expect but if the
ukrainians have got any heavy equipment
onto there I don't know if they have but
if they have almost certainly they'll
start to move to the south in other
words they've crossed to the other side
of the river in the south in the north
at uh novakovka the the Russian
delegated governor of novakovka acting
for the Russians has said he wanted a
10-mile exclusion Zone away from the
river because they expect the ukrainians
to come across the the uh the dam at
novakovka novocacy is on the south side
of the river so if they if that falls
then the the ukrainians are in a
position to sort of create a pincer
movement to to get the Russians to
withdraw from person that's the next
stage of the battle and that's why I say
the battle cursing is only half one
they've got to get the the Russians out
of artillery range before the city is
safe yeah Ukraine being spoken about a
lot at the G20 Summit that's got
underway today in Bali in fact the U.S
President Joe Biden is talking about it
a short time ago he was asked by a
journalist you know
is this is this the pivotal moment in
the war and he said it's too early to
say yet is that how it's going to be
treated at the G20 Summit in terms of
proceeding with caution as you said it's
only half one what what can be done at
the G20 Summit to affect what's
happening yeah in Ukraine well things
are changing strategically because
Crimea is now
um under threat because of what the uh
the Ukraine's have been able to do in
person because they're now within range
and the Russians will have trouble
moving the troops that they've just
relieved as it were by getting across
the river they want to move them to
Donetsk into this front which is where
the fight fighting is really fierce but
I have trouble doing that if the
ukrainians are keeping going and keeping
attacking them so it is a strategic
issue and at the G20
um in a way the the Russians will say
what they always say these things lavrov
will turn up as he did in July to the
G20 he'll he'll blame the West he'll say
it's all fake news and he'll leave you
won't go away the um I mean he won't
stay or just go home and the issue then
is well what message does he take back
to President Putin and that's the issue
really I mean the they're very unpopular
this is not by any means the turning
point in the war this is not the
beginning of the end but it might turn
out to the end of the beginning of
Churchill famously said Okay Michael
thank you Professor Michael Clarke there
with analysis of what's happening in
Ukraine